doch wird präsentiert vom neuen toyota
rav 4 4 x 4 und hybrid die ideale
kombination für die schweiz
[Musik]
schonungslos begrüßt heinz carrick die
15 teilnehmer zu dieser gastro
ausbildung im luzernischen emmen drücken
es sind anerkannte flüchtlinge und
vorläufig aufgenommene alle leben schon
seit zwei und mehr jahren in der schweiz
sprechen einigermaßen deutsch
doch sie konnten bislang keine stelle
finden leben von der sozialhilfe das
will heißt eric gelernter koch und
erwachsenenbildner in seinem ressort
kurs ändern und gary dein erfahrene
handwerker der integration macht seine
arbeit mit viel sinn für die
wirklichkeiten priorität die vertrauten
brutal und die musik energie bringen und
das nützt da einfach mit ja wenn ich
ihnen sagt wir versuchen denn der mond
das konnte so irgendwie skurril sondern
zwei hälften triebe auf
unterricht auch in der wc anlage die
realschüler machen ihr haus wirtschafts
praktikum
es ist halbzeit im einjährigen kurs doch
nicht alles läuft so wie es sollte die
hans für sicheren kommen figuren gaben
sieben ja sogar
[Musik]
bei luzern am vierwaldstätter see wo die
welt besonders schön friedlich und
aufgeräumt ist im hotel hermitage hat
zapatero den letzten tag ihres
hauswirtschafts praktikums in ihre
heimat war die 39-jährige frau lehrerin
nun ist sie in einer neuen schweizer
arbeitswelt angekommen wenigstens mal
für fünf praktikumswochen die hübschen
brote auf diesem see dienen
ausschliesslich dem schönen leben doch
sabbats ära erinnern sie an ihre chefs
fahrt über das mittelmeer 600 menschen
drängten sich damals im überfüllten
alten kann aus dem sie nur diese tasche
retten konnte
spuren einer gemeinsamen reise die auch
tödlich hätte enden können
das austritts gespräch mit ihrer chefin
barbara drauf zeigt beidseitig eine
große zufriedenheit
und gibt es auch etwas das sie ihnen
weniger gut gefahren haben gibt es so
etwas
alles ist schön zu hören der flüchtlings
kurs findet seine fortsetzung in
emmenbrücke luzern
dort trifft sich die klasse nach dem
praktikum in räumlichkeiten der
einstigen textilfabrik bis kurse wie
hart wir das praktikum gefallen auf der
einen seite oder überhaupt nicht
gefallen und dann warum dann möchte ich
von ihnen hören warum war das so
die meisten waren sehr zufrieden viele
gar zu 100 prozent kursleiter heinz
gehrig kann es kaum glauben
jetzt wird es mir langsam unheimlich
rhede rom gehört sein auch salate rey
hatte fünf gute praktikumswochen einzig
ein erlebnis hatte sie betrübt du keine
test so finden arbeit keine fans ihre
dinkel die frau angst nehmen ihre arbeit
flachs was aber sie haben das super
durch sie haben im prinzip die eine
antwort schon gegeben oder diese frau
hat angst gehabt das ist eine
konkurrentin weil die haben alle angst
dass sie besser sind und wenn sie besser
sind bekommen sie die stelle weil wir
wollen ja nur die besten im arbeitsmarkt
25 prozent warum nicht 100 also
was haben sie negative lebt ali haschemi
der 19 jährige afghane hat es eine
praktikumsstelle verloren weil er
mehrmals unentschuldigt nicht zur arbeit
erschienen war
seine erklärung für dieses verhalten die
betreuerin habe nur portugiesisch
gesprochen aber doch etwas haben wir
gelernt so die rückmeldungen der
praktikumsbetriebe sehen durchzogen aus
die person wirkt sehr unmotiviert nicht
erscheinen wenn sie krank sind und sie
telefoniere mit
das geht nicht die person ist nicht
belastbar wird schnell müde und immer
etwas tut weh also eure rücken tut weh
tut weh dass ich nur mal was wir dann
sehr gut gefallen hat ist ich habe viele
viele rückmeldungen bekommen dass die
persönliche hygiene sehr gut war das hat
mich wahnsinnig gefreut
also hier muss etwas passieren weil so
geht's nicht das wäre eine absolute
katastrophe
15 personen und nur selbst personen
haben eine stelle alle anderen keine
chance
ich weiß es ist von da wo sie herkommen
ist die arbeit komplett anders und jetzt
kommen sie in ein komisches system wie
die schweiz und jetzt müssen sie vom von
irgendwo auf 100% 150 prozent hoch das
ist
nicht einfach das braucht zeit aber man
muss es schaffen
ich möchte mit diesem kurs eine
hundertprozentige erfolgsquote weil ich
bin sicher alle von ihnen können darf im
zürcherischen fight wird ein neues
tagungszentrum eröffnet hier sollen
künftig castro ausbildungskurse
durchgeführt werden
als sprecher ist ernst bachmann geladen
präsident des zürcher wird der verbandes
und kantonsrat der schweizerischen
volkspartei seine partei die svp könnte
die wirte noch in nöte bringen
hier maßen ihre initiative februar 2004
zu wort und stellt natürlich auch für
die branche große herausforderung der
rat als landschaftlich im moment in etwa
50 prozent dass ich eben gas strebe
immer traditionell höhe und bachmann
spricht über seine eigenen erfahrungen
mit flüchtlingen
er hat jetzt gab letztendlich profit
macht dass ich so einen dollar board ist
einer der links das ist der flieder der
eritrea
er hat vor zwei jahren grafik macht koch
klärt
und der hat sein chef karl peter bruch
dieses vergehen es liegt da für mich
haus problem das alle waren bei mir
bleiben wollen bei ernst bachmann
bleiben
da hat er das gleiche problem wie das
ganze land
das restaurant mucken bühl eingangs von
zürich hier wird ernst bachmann der
svp-politiker das alte haus verströmt
schweizerisches traditionsbewusstsein
doch in der küche hat sich die ganze
welt versammelt
meinte samuel das haben wir schon vor
jahren hat doch hochkreativen jahre und
die schätze ich zwei jahren haben und
sagen wir ich das richtig zwei jahre als
fraglich ob immer mehr beschäftigen
dann haben wir da ahnte können sie
schnell die puste haben dankte erich
seit 28 jahren
jaja erlaubten 20 ja und dann namen der
sieger deutscher sohn um das ist jetzt
der hertie beta grafik macht der report
die wiederverkäufer abgeschlossen
katrin ihr verrückt sie das gibt es ja
gut dann haben wir da das sie war
sie war wie lange bist du bei liebe chef
18 jahre jetzt unter küchenchef das
komitee und das ist jetzt der libanon
jetzt als hoch angestellte botschaft für
das jahr wohl kochlehre und erhalte ich
jetzt in einem kurs kelly es wird ernst
bachmann hat schon mehrere flüchtlinge
aus dem risiko kurs angestellt
fachkräftemangel
es werde über die artemis machen dafür
und mehr hand mit jährigen vor hoch wie
heimchen thema der zurückschauen dann
sind die mitarbeiter koche ich vernehme
sagen ob die wirkte muss bilder und mit
einer ds politische bis völlig neues
zeitalter endlich jemand die wissen du
machst das gab multikulturell also
während
[Musik]
es bringt einfach nur die kulturelles
und gewann 2 über den svp-politiker
bekenntnis der politik indem sie läuft
da wär ich bewerte und vertrat wird in
der modernen küche wird ein
erstaunliches phänomen deutlich wie es
auch in zahlreichen anderen schweizer
betrieben zu tage tritt bekommen
ausländischer menschen namen und
gesichter werden aus einst bedrohlichen
fremden gute fremde ausland dafür mit
sind einfach manche und muss man es
überhaupt für das verständnis mehr waren
die übrigen kuwait menschen sich für
dich also alles wenn man ja an den
stammtischen seiner partei mag ob der
vielen fremden streit ausgebrochen sein
in der küche des svp wird es hingegen
herrscht frieden die flüchtlinge lernen
sich auf dem schweizer arbeitsmarkt zu
verkaufen die eigenen vorzüge zu
entdecken und anzupreisen ali haschemi
hat in den letzten tagen erneut gefehlt
im unterricht 1 gehrig holt den afghanen
raus zu einer aussprache
prof hand der winkel shawn levy nicht
einmal für sich irgendein nicht
bestätigt ja so sind sie mit ihrem
talent das glaubt dass insgesamt sogar
vier geschwistern vor der ursache suchen
ab mit messages immer wenn es sogar im
gefängnis oder im tod oder sogar bitte
so schnell wie möglich über die grenze
bevor der zaun fertig ist das sagen sich
derzeit tausende von flüchtlingen die
auf der sogenannten balkan unter
unterwegs sind sie versuchen von
mazedonien oder serbien in die eu zu
gelangen
es sind nachrichten die heißt eric
betreten
während die masse von flüchtlingen
unterwegs und da ich so maschine ganz
europa muss umdenken auch habe also mehr
der schweiz könnte doch nicht vorstellen
wo ich mit einer litern was beschäftigt
sie hofft mit tante lucie integrieren
wenn sie die filme gesehen da kommt ein
sitzgefühl möchte ich mir dass sie sie
fußen
mich hat es vor der rest ist sie sich
sagen bedeutet ich hallo wie ein aber es
ist nicht die leute sind ja da und die
briefe und darum ist es eigentlich nicht
in situationen aber die zukunft die ltm
und irgendeine idee arbeitsmarkt und
führt aus sind eine mehrseitige projekt
noch in petto die bliebe da und das muss
man sich einfach bewusst sind und da
haben wir einfach nicht machen
das war hat einen charakter ist offen
heinz gehrig ist unterwegs nach
winterthur an der dortigen technischen
fachschule läuft ein risko kurs der
flüchtlinge in gebäude und
automobiltechnik ausbildet
ja minimalst aber so erheblich gesagt
lassen wir es gelten gewesen andreas
schröder unterrichtet flüchtlinge in
automobiltechnik für diese jungen männer
ist das eine traum ausbildung und auch
sonst seien die flüchtlinge in seinen
kursen motiviert ihr leben in den griff
zu kriegen
weg von der sozialhilfe sie sehen in den
augen es klar ich möchte mein geld
verdienen ich möchte nichts geschenkt
haben
und der satz finde ich die gefahr dass
sie blüten muss sagen ich möchte nicht
immer aufs amt gehen und fragen sondern
ich möchte mein eigenes geld verdienen
das ist jetzt ins prozent oder ein
mobiles und iris kater findus prozent
immer was sie einst gierig und andrea
schröder besprechen die rückmeldungen
der praktikumsbetriebe haben wir genau
das sehen allerdings sind auch immer
wieder kulturelle hürden zu überwinden
diese auch an jan o diskutiert weiß ich
genau wieder die kulturelle probleme
sind
das macht sie jetzt ganz böse regierung
und der darin gipfelt dass antwort das
machen bei uns nur die rosco kurse in
gebäude und automobiltechnik und auch
jene in gastronomie sind erfolgreiche
aber teure kurse wohl wegen der hohen
kosten werden sie nur in zwei kantonen
luzern und zürich angeboten machen viele
14 dagegen bis man realisiert zu tag ein
lehrer einen reifen zu wechseln wenn man
auto aber das war eigentlich wie das
führt dazu weiter zum schluss wieder vom
arbeitsmarkt zins zwar schnell neue
maschinen her schnell wieder neu mit
tusche und gesagt wir machen nur mit war
möglich qualitativ gute ausbildung
machen und das ist ganz klar
immer wieder schaffen es absolventen des
kurses die ausbildung mit einer lehre
fortzusetzen
der handschlag auch so ein brauch der in
anderen weltgegenden unüblich ist und
den heinz gehrig in seinen kursen zum
thema machen muss
bestellen könnt und die stones ändert
eine lücke trotz da ist das ganzen tag
die kombos und spezielle den across
ob die männer monaco ist das wirklich
einfach vorhinein uns ruhig und zwar
nach dem sfz sondern bieten
das ist born es sind diese heißen august
trage die temperaturen über 30 grad
bringen
die halbe schweiz ist in den ferien doch
ferien gibt es für die flüchtlings
klasse keine es ist die vierte woche der
küchen ausbildung bei koch lehrerin
martina brändle einem ice krise soll es
heute geben danach seit dem broker mit
risotto und eine creme charlott royal
weil nicht nur die muslime in der klasse
sondern auch die orthodoxen christen aus
eritrea essen kein schweinefleisch
untersagt ist in diesen kulturen
überdies der alkohol
deshalb muss die koch lehrerin die
rezepte immer etwas anpassen und so gibt
die creme charlott royal halt ohne
kirsch
für ali haschemi den 19 jährigen
afghanen muss nicht mehr aufgetischt
werden nachdem er erneut unentschuldigt
dem unterricht ferngeblieben war musste
er den kurs verlassen
[Musik]
ali haschemi hat eine große chance
vertan auf dem sportplatz in willisau wo
er früher fußball spielte ringt er um
eine erklärung
das sehe ich mir eine falle und das ist
nicht mitgemacht haben
ich ersuche ich bedanke mich ärgere
das ist sozusagen eine chance gehabt
aber ich als zusatz zum nicht ch ich
kann einfach das gemacht was ich im kopf
gar schweiz ist die einzige besten
langweilig oder zu machen
das hotel waldstetter hof in luzern seit
jahren schon können flüchtlinge aus dem
unesco kurs hier die realität kennen
lernen es ist der zweite woche des
küchen praktikums für den eritrea
amerika tisch frei und den afghanen visa
will ali attieh die beiden haben in
diesem hotel bereits das hauswirtschafts
praktikum gemacht man kennt sie hier
und man mag sie die beiden ruhigen
arbeitsamen männer isabella at ist
glücklich dass er hier arbeiten darf
doch da ist immer auch eine tiefe
melancholie die sprache von leuten ich
kann es später besser mit nötig aber
hier ist beim ist der später durch oder
wir deswegen ich komme kommt darf machte
mit dem ich ein bisschen deswegen nicht
mittragen mein land ist bis jetzt mit
was ist schon normal sein leider in
meinen
im hinblick der taliban hat meine mutter
oder vater geprügelt
und da habe ich erst mal ganz kurz
grausam ist die lebensgeschichte von
isabella hatte doch seine
liebenswürdigkeit dieser sich nicht
nehmen und dann kurz vor mittag bricht
wie jeden tag die große hektik aus in
der küche
[Musik]
[Applaus]
am urnersee bei fühlen fast in
sichtweite zum rütli so wie man sagt die
schweiz ihren anfang nahm
[Applaus]
einmal im monat spielt heinz gierig beim
schloss rudenz mit einigen freunden
bitte nicht alle stammbäume dieser
männer reichen bis zum rütli zurück
einige vorfahren kann als italienische
gastarbeiter zum tunnel und autobahnbau
ins land an bord hat geblieben sind die
italienischen namen doch der rest ist
werks turnerisch geworden
klar die einwanderung die neuen fremden
sind auch hier ein brennendes thema
heinz gehrig der in jungen jahren auf
allen kontinenten gekocht hat berichtet
über ein schlüsselerlebnis
und ich weiß eigentlich 900 oben vl
unterweisen und da haben wir steht dass
so ein hutu familie im bus so haben
nicht wieder zusammengeflickt und filme
trotzdem flexibel aber der kleine
melodie gesorgt berichtet dass oder
warum der sohn die hand einfach komplett
und das in so ein spiel wo erschien die
mich dazu bewogen hat vertraut sich lied
setzen können dann aber doch ich sage
dir wie du musst mal wieder reicher zu
rift express motive die jenes nicht bloß
freundschaftlich musste für die jene
dass so viele fremde menschen in die
schweiz kommen beschäftigt die hunger
männer 1 gehrig erzählt von seiner
arbeit
wie sollen in einer und fragen sich
dänemark die schweiz und der helm
reinigen dynamik sein verhalten war bis
zum internet und zwar die die bauwerke
kunden ein bad mit dem hart zu futtern
und der goalie der große trumpf mit dem
peter lee unterhalt des es seien gerade
in so kurzer zeit stellte vor wie die
der münchener und das ist durch schloss
und vergisst mannschaft natürlich
hintergrund der aktivitäten der 1000
also ich der trotz place wird für die
richtige musik integrieren so stolz
garten
das muss ob es das beste mit minze
versuchen integrierte man muss eine job
kam aber es eine vernünftige jetzt kann
wenn das salz spiel grundsatz und die
haben probleme die unternehmen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
etwas außerhalb von luzern das hotel
hermitage
letzter tag des küchen praktikums von
tashi zahn
der anfang war hart todmüde war der
junge tibeter jeweils abends bleischwer
die knochen doch er hat durchgestanden
der küchenchef ist sehr zufrieden was
mir gefällt ist das ist ein sehr
aufnahmefähig dass man kann ihnen etwas
erklären und der zeit vor machen und
dann setzt sie das ist der spiegel schon
gleich tun haben sie wirklich toll
gemacht sind immer mit elan dran
geblieben und vor allem was mir sehr
gefehlt
auch in mit einem rechen ich finde erst
einmal dass ich also in kirchen zu
arbeiten und die kunst also viele von
hier erfahrung und das bin ich sehr
zufrieden
anfang november nach dem praktikum
findet der iosco kurs seine fortsetzung
wieder in emmenbrücke nagelfeile schön
fallen die damen ja dass sie gut da
schon viel viel viel besser da noch ein
bisschen dran arbeiten überall bereich
kurz sagt ja sind sie zufrieden
es ist der fünfwöchige service kurs eine
wahre herausforderung für die
flüchtlinge nicht nur was das richtige
platzieren der fliege anbelangt wenn sie
mit zehn stunden arbeiten sie kommen am
abend noch einmal an die arbeit der
vielen sich die männer zwei mal und zwar
einmal duschen rutscher leuthold leitet
den service kurs seit seinem dritten
lebensjahr sei ja der gastronomie
verwöhnen sagt der kursleiter das
servieren sei der beste beruf der welt
und das will er seinen schülern mit
allen mitteln verdeutlichen
jetzt komme ich zum gast und frage sind
sie bedient darf ich aber räumen sind
sie bedient darf ich abholen
jetzt nehme ich diesen teller wieder mit
der rechten hand nicht mit der linken
oder nicht mit der linken wieder mit der
rechten hand auf und übergebe ihnen
wieder der linken habe als ich ein
reines ping und paul hin und her
für die menschen aus afrika und asien
bedeutet all das wirklich eine neue welt
wir haben viele verschiedene gläser
verschiedene und dann geht es erneut
holz hohen service schule tatsächlich
die höhe
in den sechsten stock der erster stock
der tibeter cheetah schied am ist um
diese zeit zwischen oma herumgekommen
er hat den kurs vor einigen tagen
verlassen
[Musik]
der abgang des 19 jährigen ist eine
erfolgsmeldung tasche hat selbst eine
stelle gesucht und diese im luzerner
restaurant tibits bekommen wer eine
anstellung findet darf den release cocos
jederzeit verlassen
aus dem einstigen tibetischen bauern
jungen ist ein adretter kenner geworden
[Musik]
und so ein bisschen mit dem gast zu
reden
da habe ich ein bisschen gefunden
taschen hat es dank der gastro
ausbildung geschafft an die natürlich
gefragt wie sieht es mit dem kurs und
die antwort war klar wenn ihr job finden
kann ich gebrauchen und da mir jemanden
mit gastro erfahrung tasche hat sein
ziel erreicht
doch es bleibt der größte wunsch dass er
bald in kontakt treten kann mit seinen
eltern die unter chinesischer besatzung
in der tibetischen heimat leben seit
vier jahren hat der 19-jährige nichts
mehr von ihnen gehört
es ist die zweite woche im service kurs
und die kursleiter müssen notfallmässig
anreisen die klasse ist in aufruhr ist
verzweifelt die flüchtlinge fühlen sich
überfordert vom unterricht zu viele
fachausdrücke davon die meisten in
unverständlichem französisch nicht
verstehen zwei wochen in silvis und
alles mit denen die probleme stehen
abend gehen auch nicht gerade zu den
auslesen
was leser nicht mitglied klären
sie haben es in einem jahr das haben sie
alles gelernt werden die unternehmen
stärken schwächen
sie haben gelernt anteile
hauswirtschaft küche überall hat es
fachwörter jetzt kommen neue fachwörter
dazu sie dürfen nicht denken dass jetzt
alles sofort sich merken können wir
wollen nicht dass sie uns sehen
weißweine aufzählen können wenn sie mir
zwei sagen können bin ich happy
mehr brauche ich nicht sie müssen mir
auch nicht sämtliche trocken erklären
können auch das brauchen wir nicht
aber sie müssen wissen dass es einen
weißen wein gibt einen roten und einen
rose heinz gierig ist gefordert
es sind nur noch wenige wochen bis zum
ende des schuljahrs und er muss die
verunsicherte klasse wieder ins punkt
holen
immer wenn sie die situation haben dass
sie etwas nicht verstehen
machen sie so und dann weise rückhalt
hauptstadt
und dann wird er von nun an fragen was
verstehen sie nicht
perica tesfai ein besonders
pflichtbewusster und ehrgeiziger schüler
hatte den service unterricht sogar
weinend verlassen
weil wenn sie das es würde niemand
verstehen ging im abendkurs meinen
ganzen ich spüre dass sie ein bisschen
zeit für sich zu haben gehen sie ihn
heute nach hause und morgen kommen sie
ganz normal ich gestand können sie ein
bisschen heulen dann in eine woche
glaube ich wieder vorbei da werden wir
jetzt haben wir eine lösung
das schuljahr ist fast schon überstanden
da werden die flüchtlinge noch aufs
glatteis geführt diese männer und frauen
haben schon gewaltmärsche durch den
himalaja den irrsinn der taliban und
traumatische boots passagen auf der
mittelmeer überlebt
da werden sie auch noch dass du zeller
glatteis überstehen
irgendwie immer wieder aufstehen
wie im richtigen leben das haben sie
alle schon gemacht sonst wären sie nicht
hier
[Musik]
als wäre es nicht schon genug gewesen
mit dem glatteis rät heinz gehrig die
klasse am mittag zu einem ford dessen
leben ein stück brot haben die gabe und
dann machen sie wie eine acht andré rain
in den mund heinz gerät lässt sich
nichts anmerken
doch eigentlich ist ihm nicht nach vorn
die fröhlichkeit zu mutter vor einigen
tagen hat er erfahren dass der kanton
luzern nächstes jahr auf die
weiterführung der iosco sie verzichten
will
nach acht jahren
der release korpus vor neun jahren
initiiert vom damaligen justizminister
blocher gewürdigt von der heutigen
justizministerin sommaruga
es ist ein schweizerisches
pionierprojekte in der beruflichen
integration von flüchtlingen in dem auch
der luzerner asyl koordinator rote fahne
eigentlich gute noten aus stellt das
außerordentlich erfreuliches angebot mit
dem man immer gerne zurück schafft
verdient
erfreulich auch dass nicht nur die
aufsuchende ihre fähigkeiten können
winter entwickeln
erfreulich habe dass man rund 70 bis 80
prozent von deiner person jeweils ein
erster arbeitsmarkt vermitteln
und doch hat der kanton luzern diesen
integrationskurs nun sistiert
die sehr gestört hat dass das angebot
der braucht eigentlich nur zum ziel hat
dass man sie noch als hoch gepusht und
vermittler sprechen hilfstätigkeit mir
ein bisschen luft zu enge türen sie das
ist natürlich klar dass wenn wir nicht
über eine gruppe dort für
führungspersonen volkmer in rom den
aushilfskraft aber dass ich viel mehr
möglichkeit dass hinter hinter eine neue
werk soll sie dass man auch angebot
wirtschaft wohin suchen die noch
möglichkeit händler abschluss zu machen
die 15 rüthemann ist er begleitete die
marisk o kurs hat überhalb der liga
machen jetzt mit dem stand wo sie mit
braucht hand keine chance da hat nie
mehr innerer leere vertrag unterbreitet
dollar entspricht die integration hat
noch nicht stattgefunden
sie sind noch nie so fit das sieht
arbeitsmarktfähigkeit behaupten land hat
und mit 0 rucksack und bezog von proof
hatte keine chance die release kurse
werden von hotel und gastro formation
angeboten der ausbildungsorganisation
der schweizer gastrobranche in weg ist
hier ist heinz gierig für die
basisausbildung in der ganzen schweiz
zuständig die arbeit wird immer also
nicht ausgehen
und doch gierig ist ob dem luzerner
entscheid konsterniert ich hoffe es
nicht nur ich weiß d'resultat sind gut
der got me sing gut es funktioniert und
das kann mir dort nachfragen mit den
anderen konnten
es hat mir persönlich sehr dürfe der
kanton luzern möchte künftig günstigere
kurse denn die aufwändigere jesko
ausbildung ist teuer und 26.000 franken
bezahlt der kanton pro kurs teilnehmer
allerdings das ist etwa so viel wie ein
stellenlose flüchtling jährlich an
sozialhilfe kostet man könnte also auch
zum schluss kommen dass dieser kurs
kosten sehr gut investiert sind
[Musik]
nervös hingegen nach das soll so sein
die prüfung ist nicht einfach wir wollen
viel wissen wir wollen mehr wissen als
es manchmal vielleicht nötig ist aber je
mehr als sie wissen umso besser wir dass
ihnen nachher gehen die schüler sind
angespannt in zwei tagen ist das
schuljahr zu ende
heute sind die abschlussprüfungen in den
fächern kochen und service in der küche
im untergeschoss macht sich die eine
hälfte der klasse für die koch prüfung
bereit
suppe nach bauart dies einer der gänge
des prüfungs - ein vier gang menü soll
schließlich werden
zum abschluss eine französische creme
mit dem erscheinungsbild
wir sind gut die socken haben wir uns
noch ganz schnell an er hier das prima
also das dunkel wird und hoffen dass das
hält sebi unterbrochen kurse oder
aufgehellt mit der fliege dann die
fingernägel
sie sehen gut aus
dieses gas ist ein anti rhd
wie heißt diese gabe das ist eine kecke
betreten gabel mit dieser garten neben
mir dann aus dem haus ist
geschmackssache
[Musik]
das ist genug
moses g.co aus uganda muss den
küchenchef spielen
der journalist und
menschenrechtsaktivist der vor der
gewalt gegen homosexuelle in seiner
heimat floh als schon pläne für die zeit
nach dem kurs er möchte an der luzerner
hochschule einen englischsprachigen
tourismus lehrgang beginnen
diese castro ausbildung sollen helfen
leben und studium zu finanzieren
dann haben sie schön gefordert auf vier
arten gefaltet und all die bestecke all
die vielen gläser isabella die der
flüchtlinge aus afghanistan hat die
anfänge der schweizer service kunst
gemacht hat und das wäre wirklich schön
wenn wir sie in der schweiz in einem
restaurant mal antreffen könnte der
service mitarbeiter der natürlich
probieren sie es ein job zu finden im
silvester kurz hinter dem haus geschafft
dass meine politische danke viel man
hätte gern gesehen
eine prüfungsarbeit zum verspeisen
dargereicht von damen aus eritrea nach
allen regeln der gastronomie
[Musik]
es ist der tag vor heiligabend und es
verspricht ein wunderbarer tag zu werden
[Musik]
heinz gehrig bereitet seinen letzten
auftritt vor
heute findet die schlussfeier statt
ganze jahr und muss ich sagen es auch
starke goalies schon vermietet
aber wenn ich bezeichne karl uhr kann
man sich sehr sehr gute resultat als
erste geladen sind die betreuerinnen und
bekannte sowie vertreter der gastro
porsche ich begrüße sie an der
diesjährigen abschlussfeier um
regulierung 2015 in emmenbrücke
ich weiß dass sie in diesem land einen
großen spagat machen müssen mit einem
fuß sind sie in ihre heimat um mit der
man dann sind sie hier
ich weiß nicht ob ich es genauso gut
hingekriegt hätte wie sie wenn ich an
ihrer stelle wäre dieser kurs hilft mir
auf meinem weg zur selbständigkeit und
macht unabhängig von der sozialhilfe und
ich auch sie fröhlich das her geht ist
unsere
sehr erfreulich wurde hat uns geholfen
zu viel und ich bin sehr fröhlich vor
diesen kursen das war super für mich und
ich bin zufrieden heute einen schönen
tag nach den letzten rückmeldungen von
den praktikums bin ich eigentlich
überzeugt da würde ich heute
unterschreiben dass jeder von ihnen eine
stelle finden wir da bin ich 100 prozent
überzeugt die wahl und so gut
frau sawatzki dafür haben sie ein jahr
lang gekämpft und manchmal auch gelitten
das risko zertifikat das ihnen nun zu
einem neuen leben verhelfen soll
so viel motivation und so viel wie von
ihm
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
heute kochen und servieren die
lehrerinnen und lehrer
[Musik]
sollten
red
lifestyle
[Musik]
er gibt
[Applaus]
münchen
[Musik]
ein gutes neues jahr
ja natürlich ging es los
ja noch lange her der zither land und
das kap aigner sieht das haben wir
spüren auch die teilnahmen
der intercity seriöse freude zu können
sie sich auch bewerben
auf der anderen seite ja so mancher hat
monaco
ja es ist ein risiko
[Musik]
doch mit dem neuen toyota rav4 firma 4
und hybrid die ideale kombination für
die schweiz